-Our first guests tonight
have worked for decades
in the highest levels
of politics,
policy, and philanthropy.
One has served as Senator,
Secretary of State,
and won the popular vote
for president.
The other is vice chair
of the Clinton Founda --
That's just math, everybody.
Of the Clinton Foundation
and a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
Their docuseries "Gutsy" is
streaming now on Apple TV Plus.
Let's take a look.
-You got this.
Come up one more. Right.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Now hold --
hold with both hands.
Put your body
in front of my body.
-Alright. I'm ready.
-You ready?
Circle, circle. There you go.
Let's move.
One step forward. Go.
-Wow. It's so heavy.
-You have heart.
-Well, yeah.
-Mom's like,
"You don't know my baby."
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back. I'm so happy
to have you both here.
-We are so --
-We are happy to be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh. Yes. Hi.
-I'm not alone in my happiness.
I just got to ask right away,
having seen the clip,
which is -- Be honest.
Which is harder -- front of hose
or back of hose? Because...
-Front of hose.
-Okay, thank you.
And who actually
got to put on all the gear?
-Yeah. I feel like
that was maybe a giveaway
that your job
was more like a fire person.
-Yes, thank you.
They didn't even ask my mom.
-Really?
-She didn't even
have to turn them down.
They just didn't ask her.
-Now, would you have turned
them down if they had said,
"You want to fire fight,"
don't you?
-No, I would not
have turned them down.
-She would have said,
"My daughter."
-That's right. We did that
all through the series,
which was so incredibly fun
for us to do together.
And there would be
all these activities
because we didn't want to just
have the usual interview show.
-And the guests
set the activities.
-Yeah, we said to the guests,
"What should we do?"
So when we knew
we were going to go out
to the training academy
for the Fire Department
of New York
to interview these
incredible women firefighters,
including one of the very first
who was really a pioneer,
we got out there, we said,
"Oh, so what do you want to do?"
You know, he said, "Well,
we want you to put on the gear.
And we won't put
all the gear on you.
We'll only put 50 pounds
of the gear on you."
And I said, "You know,
my daughter would really like
to do that."
-True story, true story.
-Well, I think, you know,
anytime, you know, a parent
can travel with a child,
it's -- you know, it's a gift.
-Yes.
-Especially when they're
adult children.
-Right.
-That makes a huge difference.
-It makes
a very big difference.
-But I'm wondering
how traveling now together
is compared to your time
traveling together
as members of the first family.
Is it massively different?
-Well, I mean, it's just
regular most of the time.
We just get on airplanes at,
like, LaGuardia or Newark or JFK
and go to wherever
we're going to go.
Now, to be fair, I still
do have Secret Service
because I was once first lady.
So that's a little different
because we can
count on getting a car
and not standing
at the rental-car counter
wondering whether we're going
to get a car, you know?
-Is there ever a Secret Service
agent looking at his phone
saying, "The Uber.
It's so weird.
Because it said five,
and now it says eight."
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to really talk
to them when they get here, yes.
It was so much fun.
-It also was similar, Seth,
in the way that we've always
had a lot of fun together.
We've always wanted to have
new experiences together.
My parents have thankfully
been always not only encouraging
but expecting me
to be curious about people
and new experiences
and the world.
And so in some ways
this felt like a continuation
and also different because,
you know, I was old enough
to have a drink with my mom
at the end of the day.
Which I wasn't 30 years ago.
-Right.
-That's very true.
-And I would imagine, too,
because of the life
that you've lived,
you have to make
pretty extreme choices
to find yourself
in a new experiences,
which you did in Paris.
-We did. We did in Paris, yes.
-So, Hillary,
I'm going to show a photo.
-Oh, come on. Okay.
-In the moment this happened,
you on screen even said...
-What have I gotten myself into?
-I think this still
catches that exact moment.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Well --
-The red nose
that launched a thousand
right-wing memes.
-Exactly. I'm already using it
as a meme in response
to texts from my wife.
-Well, I'm always glad
to be of service.
And, you know,
when it was suggested
that we go to Paris
to clown school,
because we were doing an --
a whole episode
about women are funny,
like, women get the last laugh.
Because when I was growing up,
everybody said,
"Oh, women aren't funny"
and I said, "Well, I watch
'I Love Lucy' all the time.
I think she's really funny."
-Yeah.
-And so, we said,
"Okay, we'll go."
But I have to confess.
I was pretty skeptical.
It was one of the most
amazing experiences.
Talk about experiences
I did not have as first lady.
-This is the clown school.
-Going to clown school.
Yeah, yeah.
I felt like I was, like,
in a comic all the time,
but I wasn't actually wearing a
red nose when I was first lady.
-That must be like
when somebody comes over to you
with a thing of seltzer.
That must be tricky
for Secret Service.
-Yeah, that --
-Is this clowning?!
Is this an attack?!
-"Put the seltzer in the bag."
But there we were literally
on the stage of the Moulin Rouge
actually taking
a clowning lesson.
And people like Sacha Baron
Cohen and Emma Thompson --
people you know have gone
to this clowning school.
We think you should go.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know --
I know many who would tell you,
"Oh, he's clown enough."
-But until you put on
that red nose
and have that sense
of vulnerability
but also possibility, who knows?
-You actually filmed an episode
with my colleague Amber Ruffin.
-Yes.
-And you actually spent time
with her at her home, I believe.
-We did.
-How did you find your time
with Amber?
I can certainly speak to mine,
but how did you enjoy her,
Chelsea?
-Hilarious, warm.
She made us feel like
we could be funny.
You know, we think we're funny,
but then she made us think that
she would maybe find us funny.
And she laughed a lot,
so hopefully
she did and we succeeded.
I just -- You know, Seth,
I found her not only
so warm and generous
and supportive and encouraging,
I also found her really wise.
Like, she just had a real wisdom
about how she thought
about comedy,
how she thought about her show
and who was part of her show.
We got to be part
of her writers' room.
She wrote a really
hilarious skit for my mother
in a pants-suit faceoff.
And I just thought like,
"Oh, this is wise."
She's wise and funny.
-This is gonna make
her impossible to be around,
everything you just said.
-Oh, sorry.
-The amount she's gonna
stand up in meetings now
and be like,
"If you'll remember, I'm wise!"
I have a million more questions
for you guys.
We're gonna take a quick break.
We'll be right back with more
from Hillary
and Chelsea Clinton.